make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
someday love will find you
break those chains that bind you
what's going on guys this is rob and i
can't be sue uh too awful loud moey is
still
sleeping in the next room so we are
covering
dark knight's death metal number three
this is gonna have a moment in this
comic where it's gonna be the most
batman moment that's ever existed in the
history of comics and i feel like
everybody who's ever been
against batman will just use it as like
a sounding call of like see
i told you like i feel like that's
what's gonna happen okay so for those of
you guys who are just joining us two
things have happened since the last
video that we did the first major thing
is that the batman who laughs has fully
taken on or at least begun to take on
the power of dr manhattan but he's not
at full strength yet that's an important
distinction that we had to kind of you
know solidify
and specify in the last video that we
did that he's not 100
at dr manhattan's power he's getting
there and he's learning how to use that
ability but he's still figuring it out
the other thing that happened is that
you basically had a strike force that
was led by like wonder woman
and batman and harley quinn and it
served the purpose and really i guess
what's left of swamp thing but it served
the purpose of them leaving the earth in
a giant mechanized suit more or less to
travel to apocalypse and to basically
free a lot of the heroes who were there
now the funny thing about this
is that once they arrive here they're
immediately met by what are
basically robin demons like para robins
is what they call them right now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with that the pair of demons are kind of
like the main force of dark side and
what really happens here is various
worlds that are conquered by dark side
either its citizens are destroyed on
that world or
they're conscripted and they're
basically transmogrified basically
meaning they're re-materialized and a
pair of demons to serve his own purposes
and so with that being the case
immediately these para robin showing up
here
is kind of like okay so we know that
like right off the bat this planet
apocalypse was ruled by darkseid until
a version of batman who basically became
darkseid managed to overtake it now
something else that i also want to point
out here is that happening at the same
time on apocalypse as their arrival
is basically what amounts to what's
what's known as the night glider this
guy's basically silver surfer
right i mean that's more or less what it
is batman's biggest fear is that he
becomes a character from marvel comics
that's one of his fears you've also got
a version of batman who became brainiac
but more importantly than that and
what's cooler than that is a version of
batman who became atrocitus the leader
of the red lantern court now it's called
batrocidus and i don't know how i feel
about the name but it kind of makes
sense right i mean atrocitus batrocidus
makes perfect sense but
it's cool to see this right it's cool to
basically see this idea
that like batman became atrocitus in
like the dark multiverse because
remember the dark multiverse is
basically just made up of
worlds of people's biggest fears right
so batman presumably has an infinite
number of fears and because he has an
infinite number of fears there's an
infinite number of earths where batman's
fears come to life right and this is
just a couple of them and that's what
makes this kind of interesting right is
it was literally the batman who laughs
traveling the dark multiverse and just
grabbing these different versions of
batman and then bringing them all to his
cause to basically you know lead to the
fall of earth and then expand his fear
of influence because at the end of the
day the goal of of the batman who laughs
is to destroy perpetua
right the the creator of the first
multiverse and to basically usurp her
power and then recreate the multiverse
in his own image that's the whole goal
behind what he's doing and so you
basically got the the main dc universe
batman you've got wonder woman you've
got harley quinn you've got swamp thing
and as soon as they get in here we end
up finding out that what's happening
inside this place is essentially they
look like they're looking for superman
and superman of course is being held in
stasis with this giant device that was
created by mr miracle now it wasn't done
intentionally scot-free didn't build it
for the purpose of serving this this you
know dark side batman it's one of these
things where darkseid batman basically
just probed his mind and figured out
that this kind of thing existed but
what's cool here
is it introduces new shades of
kryptonite now it doesn't really do it
insofar as you know an itemized list
right so like here's a new shade and
it's what it does and here's another
shade and here's what it does it doesn't
really work that way
instead it's just kind of like new
shades of kryptonite that basically
drain the power of superman now what
this does and this is one of those
important moments in comic books those
of you guys who are not familiar with
this
this is one of those important moments
where what's going to happen is at some
future point in time
some writers going to draw on this some
writers going to take this and then
basically say some
shade of this kryptonite was left over
from the dark multiverse and now it's
available to use
against superman and what what that
particular shade does is left to any
number of circumstances and they'll
probably hand wave it and just say the
reason why it doesn't drain is his
kryptonian cells the way that it does
right now is because it was all the
different shades working together this
one has its own properties and it does
this thing you know that's most likely
what's going to happen but it's kind of
interesting because what the
what what dark side batman does here is
play mind games with superman this is
this is cool this is actually genius of
scott snyder
because one of the things that batman is
best known for is playing mind games
it's his whole shtick
it's how he keeps gaza in line to a
degree that the average person doesn't
want to get swept up by the batman that
in a lot of ways he's more
myth than truth the batman kind of
allows these legends to sort of permeate
about what he can do that he can fly
or that he's not really even a man you
know that kind of a thing he allows
those myths to kind of exist because
they bolster to the element of fear
and help to keep gotham in line and so
playing these games with superman he
kind of says like have you ever wondered
you know why it is that in the dark
multiverse every version of yourself is
a tyrant
every version of yourself rules over the
entirety of that earth and the and the
human populace in it and those who don't
follow your lead
basically end up getting destroyed this
really kind of begs the question is
injustice part of the dark multiverse
because it's interesting to see that
reference right and it's a cool question
right like is injustice in the dark
multiverse it's an interesting question
to ask i want to know what your thoughts
are right post
post a comment down post a comment below
and let me know if you think that
injustice is in the dark multiverse but
the cool thing about this is he
basically says you were sent to earth
from a dying world and the idea was that
you could arrive here on earth and you
could help make humanity better but if
there's any one thing that you've
learned from watching humanity is that
humanity's governed by fear fear of our
own insignificance fear of death
fear of people who look different people
are afraid of any number of different
things and that fear is what guides the
entirety of humanity to make the kind of
decisions that it makes
people say we don't need to engage in
some kind of you know total destruction
of the earth not because of the fact
that like a nuclear holocaust
would be bad for the environment or it
would initiate like a nuclear winter but
because of the fear of what life under
that circumstance would be like
would they be able to survive people are
afraid of change
right people get used to things being a
certain way and they don't want things
to be different and so what dark side
batman basically hits at here is like on
these dark multiverse earths where you
rule as a tyrant you came to the
realization that the only way to truly
guide humanity is to control humanity
that if left to their own devices and if
given
perfect freedom humanity would use that
freedom to essentially destroy itself
and so it's
interesting it's it's interesting
concept because in the middle of this
whole torture scenario and if i'm being
honest with you guys this is the part of
the story where i
kind of feel like snyder falls a little
short but like as soon as as soon as you
know
you have wonder woman and you have the
main dc universe batman who show up and
you've got uh you know harley quinn who
shows up and swamp thing then like you
know dark side batman's like demons
attack kill them all you know and it's
like okay like you know and
and for the most part the fight kind of
progresses the way you would expect it
to you know in the sense that you've got
main dc universe batman doing his thing
you've got wonder woman doing her thing
you know that kind of situation
but the problem is that so many of
superman's kryptonian cells have
basically been destroyed that if they
yank him out of this thing he'll
immediately turn into a version of
darkseid right and so there doesn't
really seem to be any way of getting
around it now in the middle of all that
of course you basically end up having a
dark side batman who approaches you know
main dc universe batman and pulls a gun
and this is kind of a cool little moment
that scott snyder references right he
basically says it's a modified version
of the gun that darkseid used
when he shot batman during final crisis
now the difference here is that during
final crisis batman was shot and then in
turn basically ended up being time
displaced
under any normal circumstance it would
have killed him but batman's too popular
to cancel and so dc just
time displaced him and so basically it's
modified so that what it's become
is in effect the ultimate nullifier for
marvel comics now for those of you guys
who don't know what that is the ultimate
nullifier is an artifact that was
created by galactus and
it is essentially part of himself but if
a person with sufficient intelligence
and willpower fires the ultimate
nullifier out of being then that being
will simply cease to exist and it won't
be
as it won't be enough to say they don't
exist it'll be as if they never work
so nobody will remember who they are
nobody will know they ever existed like
all memories of that person will be
completely and totally wiped from the
entirety of the universe and that's
exactly what's happening here
that if we say for example that this
entire you know this the
entire uh attack launched here on
apocalypse is the idea of bruce wayne
right let's say that it was entirely his
idea
it wasn't but let's say that it was
explicitly his idea then what this would
mean is that if this bullet was pulled
or if this gun was was
the trigger was pulled the bullet hit
batman and he simply ceased to exist
from the entirety of the universe nobody
would know why they were there because
because everything from his existence
stemming forward so every idea that he's
put out all of that would simply just
vanish it would just disappear from
everybody's mind from the entire concept
of the universe it's a very meta textual
thing and of course
you know dark side batman pulls the
trigger and shoots batman
and so from there it's kind of like okay
essentially bruce wayne didn't die
right like he he didn't cease to exist
and dark side batman's like how are you
still here and he and
you know basically bruce wayne says like
to watch the next part and it's like
clerk and ultimately this basically
allows clark kent to break himself free
and the expectation is that he would
succumb to
anti-life right he would become the new
dark side but it doesn't and the reason
why
is because of the black lantern ring of
batman that the black lantern ring
basically stopped superman cells from
dying that once they got in there and
basically
it was revealed that this machine was
killing off the kryptonian cells of
superman then ultimately what it meant
is that the black lantern ring of batman
could stop the rest of these cells from
dying
and so that basically saves superman
that's why he's still here now at the
same time
uh the reason why batman didn't die is a
throwaway explanation probably the most
throwaway explanation that i've ever
seen and i feel like it's scott snyder
playing it fast and loose and just being
like yeah because he's batman you know
what other explanation do i need here
the question's asked like how did you
survive that and he's like
bat armor like a bat blocker and that's
all we get it's literally like a single
speech bubble
bat blocker and then it's just kind of
like okay he's batman he can do whatever
he wants to do right because it's what
the plot calls for and is how his
character works i feel like batman fans
are gonna be pissed they're gonna be
like man come on you know but that's
that's that's the way it goes right at
the end of the day
this particular speech bubble it really
just kind of highlights
what makes batman batman he survives
everything because he's batman right and
so from there it's kind of looking into
okay we need to find the rest of the
heroes and this is where the plan gets
really really cool because what we end
up kind of doing here is jumping over to
lobo now lobo has kind of been this wild
card scott snyder's kind of been
throwing these moments with lobo into
the comic and we don't really know what
purpose it served now it is cool to see
him just shooting up the fifth dimension
and killing everybody here right
basically
introducing you know death to a place
where death didn't exist before
even the sun's hiding behind the clouds
right like everybody's dying there and
it's just kind of like okay i don't know
how it is that lobo can kill people in
the fifth dimension but whatever man i
guess it works and then he gets he gets
up to like a tree
and then like kills the tree and then
it's like okay we switch back to
everybody else
now at this point we jump back to the
crypt of heroes and this is this is
essentially dr
fade and it's wally west and it's it's
you know the jsa and all these guys and
then they're of course met by the
arrival of
the robin king now the robin king we can
do a video on he's actually he's part of
that legends of the dark knight story
that we did we only covered one of the
origins and
we can cover the origin on this one as
well but basically it's kind of a robin
who's putting his own gadgets together
and in a lot of ways is pretty twisted
and pretty screwed up but the cool thing
is that inside of this utility belt that
he has
he's got every way to kill superheroes
seemingly in existence right so like his
own little mini version of tower of
babel and he even kind of goes as far as
to make this joke to say that like when
it comes to barry for example
one of the things that he did is he he
basically took this kind of speed force
substance and then put it on his
mother's corpse that would basically
liquefy
the muscles of barry allen right so take
like a speed force toxin and liquefy
berry's muscles and then he turned
around and stuffed it in the flash ring
right so what would happen is barry
would go to he would
you know presumably this ring would be
switched out barry would put on the the
ring that has his mother's body in it
and then he would press the button to
activate the ring and the body would
just come flying out right and then
basically wrap itself around barry which
admittedly sounds funny as hell and then
like barry's muscles would basically
liquefy
and then he would die right like in its
most horrendous way and from there like
it just kind of breaks down he doesn't
really go into specifics on everybody
else but what he says here is the reason
why he's here is seemingly to watch the
batman who laughs die right that seems
to be why the robin king is here now
again if you guys want to see that whole
story we can cover it but what they also
realize is the batman who laughs is
coming and the reason why is
he's trying to get a hold of wally west
remember wally west has a portion of dr
manhattan's powers and to collect that
power from wally west would basically
allow you know the batman who last
to completely attain the full on
abilities of dr manhattan and then from
there
basically absorb anti-crisis energy so
basically the energy of perpetua or at
least what perpetua feeds on and then
overpower her
and then take over the multiverse right
so he's like two steps away from being
able to conquer everything and so the
response of of jay garrick and and barry
is we got to get wally out of here and
the question is where do we go and it's
like we do what we always do we just run
and that's all it's going to be it's
just going to be them running and the
batman who laughs
chasing after them just running in all
different locations all different places
now they're staying together as a team
because it's easier for jay and barry to
protect wall-e in that way but i
wouldn't be surprised if somewhere along
the line they end up having to break off
but from there we basically switch back
over to superman and company and of
course they rescue
pretty much all the other superheroes
who were there right so mr terrific how
jordan the green lantern uh jessica cruz
beast boy guy gardner jon stewart
nightwing all these different guys the
heroes that you for the most part know
and love and with them basically being
restored the question is okay what do we
do now and wonder woman basically
reveals this whole thing was done for
the purpose of launching a strike to
basically rescue the most powerful hero
among them and the whole idea of this
plan
is to launch an attack on multiple
fronts but basically the idea is to
travel to the citadel where perpetua is
basically collecting all this energy
from the dark multiverse and to
basically destroy these citadels the
other one is to answer enter into castle
bat
and the second thing or the third thing
is to just kind of allow the flashes to
run in order to keep wally west alive
now the way this is going to play out is
kind of cool the way the strike team has
arranged
is that jon stewart will lead the green
lanterns to basically the antennas the
kind of homing beacons where this this
energy is more or less being channeled
and take those out right to basically
cut perpetua off from her ability to
harness this energy and then in turn
you're also going to have martian
manhunter uh who's gonna go with his own
team
after her throne basically to try to
take perpetua head on and then from
there you're gonna have uh superman
wonder woman
and batman who are gonna enter back into
the dark multiverse and then enter into
castle bat basically the layer of the
batman who laughs
it's a multi-faceted action and when the
question becomes okay who's this ultra
powerful character that you're talking
about it turns out to be jarrow that
jarrow is as we know a little fraction
of staro himself and is the most
powerful psychic
in the entirety of the universe the
reason why this is so important is
because the best offense
is a good defense and that what jaro can
do is basically
psychically block the the you know
existence of wonder woman and batman and
superman
inside castle bat the biggest drawback
to this is that if anybody is hunting if
the batman who laughs
somehow either breaks off the fight or
breaks off the chase from wally west or
manages to capture him then he's gonna
he's basically probably gonna reach out
and say okay where does everything stand
at the moment are the heroes still in
apocalypse okay no they're not there
they were saved and then he's gonna
start looking around and he's gonna
realize he can't pick up wonder woman he
can't detect batman and he cannot detect
superman and that's when he he's gonna
know that something's off and then
batman who laughs
being as smart as bruce wayne is gonna
deduce they're going after his base of
operations that's most likely what's
going to happen then of course he'll
confront them head-on now i'm assuming
that i'm not really i don't know if
that's really the case
who knows i also think an important
thing to understand here is that
gyro is powerful in terms of his psychic
abilities but in terms of the most
powerful hero
in in dc comics there's a lot of heavy
hitters here
you got amazo you got captain adam you
know you got martian manhunter like
there's some
pretty heavy hitters here so to say that
jaro is the most powerful of the heroes
i think is a little bit of a stretch
but from there we basically pick up with
lobo right lobo having a conversation
with someone and he's asked do you have
the final box and the response of lobo
is yes presumably it was inside the tree
that he killed right he reached in the
tree killed it ripped its guts out and
then you know basically captured the box
and then initially it's kind of like
like lobo wants to open it and know
what's in it and he's basically told
do not open that up right if you open
that up you're going to die but
ultimately
he ends up traveling back to the person
he's talking to which is basically
revealed to be lex luthor and that what
this
is inside this box or inside these boxes
are what's called
death metal and that using this death
metal that lex luthor seems to either
want to recreate the entirety of reality
for himself
or to change things and to correct what
it was that he did wrong right we don't
really know what direction lex luthor's
coming from here
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
do
[Music]
you